okay in terms of solutions yeah I'm
going to ask you a few things so one
uh parenting yeah
five and seven year old
so I'm sure you've figured it all out
then oh God no from a free speech
perspective yeah uh from a free speech
culture perspective how to be a good
parent yeah I think the First Quality
you should be cultivating in your
children if you want to have a free
speech culture
is curiosity
and an awareness of the vastness that
will always be unknown and getting my
kids excited about the idea that's like
we're citing and endless and will never
make a big dent in it but the journey
will be amazing but only fools think
they know everything
um and sometimes dangerous fools at that
so giving the sense of intellectual
humility early on being also you know
saying things that actually do sound
kind of old-fashioned like but I say
things to my kids like listen
if you
enjoy study and work both things that I
very much enjoy I do for fun
um your life is going to feel great and
it's going to feel easy
um so some some you know some of those
old-fashioned virtues are things I try
to preach
um counter-intuitive stuff like outdoor
time playing
um having time that are not
intermediated experiences is really is
really important
and little things like I talk about in
the book about when my kids are watching
something that's scary and I'm not
talking about like zombie movies you
know I'm talking about like you know a
cartoon that has kind of a scary moment
and saying that they want to turn the TV
off and I and I talk to them and I say
listen
I'm gonna sit next to you and we're
going to finish this show
and I want you to tell me what you think
of of this afterwards and I sat next to
my sons
um and by the end of it every single
time I you know when I asked them was it
as scary as you thought it was going to
be and there was like no daddy that was
fine and I'm like that's one of the
great lessons in life the fear that you
don't
go through becomes much bigger in your
head than actually simply facing it
that's one of the reasons why I'm
fighting back against this culture I
love you know for all of our kids to be
able to grow up in an environment where
people give you Grace and you know
accept the fact that sometimes people
are going to say things that piss you
off take seriously the possibility and
be wrong and and uh be curious well I'm
I have hope that the thing you mentioned
which is because so much of young
people's stuff is on the internet that
they're going to give each other a break
because then everybody is cancer-worthy
Generation Z hates cancel culture the
most and that's another reason why it's
like people still claiming this is even
happening it's kind of like no you
actually can ask you know kids what they
think of cancer culture and they hate it
yeah well I kind of think of them as
like the immune system that's like
that's the culture waking up to like now
this is not a good thing I I am glad
though I mean I I I'm one of those kids
who you know is really glad that I was a
little kid in the 80s and a teenager in
the 90s because having everything
potentially online uh it's it's not a an
upbringing a Envy well I because you can
also do the absolute free speech
I like leaning into it yeah where I hope
for future where a lot of our
insecurities flaws
everything's out there yeah and to be
raw honest with it uh I think that leads
to a better world because the flaws are
beautiful I mean that's the flaws as the
uh the basic ingredients of human
connection uh Robert Wright he wrote a
book on on Buddhism um and I talked
about trying to use social media from a
from a Buddhist perspective and like as
if you're as if it's the collective
unconscious meditating
and seeing those little like Angry bits
that are trying to cancel you or get you
to shut up and just kind of like letting
them go the same way you're supposed to
watch your thoughts kind of Trail off I
would love to see that like visualized
whatever the whatever the drama going on
going on just seeing the Sea of it of
the collective Consciousness just
processing this and having a little like
panic attack it's just kind of like yeah
breathing it in look look at the little
sort of hateful angry voices kind of pop
up and be like okay there you are and
I'm still focused on on that thing